well it only took about 30 years but yes
Ghostbusters is finally back on the big
screen and Dan Aykroyd is right here
where that's one of the executive
producers of the new comedy nice to see
you again good Caesar we're gonna get
serious right away dan Leslie Jones has
been absolutely bombarded lately with a
series of racist and despicable tweets
oh man a sale
an all-out attack by racist internet
trolls last night Leslie Jones announces
she's had it with the offensive remarks
she's all too familiar with receiving on
Twitter and asks this of the site
Twitter I understand you got free speech
I get it
but there has to be some guidelines when
you let spread like that you can see on
the profiles that some of these people
are crazy sick it's not enough to freeze
account they should be reported these
people first of all they're
insignificant gnats they're losers they
they have no lives of their own they can
probably barely pay for the Wi-Fi
they're using probably no jobs I would
say you're looking at obese white men
between 50 and 60 who are active Klan
members or members the Aryan Nation and
there are millions of them Leslee social
media drama is the latest controversy
chasing the Ghostbusters reboot just
this past weekend the film failed to
score the number-one spot of the box
office phone falling closely behind the
secret life of pets Ghostbusters is 30
years old
you know secret life but that's a new
concept do you like to beat the guy that
you had the first weekend you want to be
above them or you want to match them and
and then in this next weekend we don't
want to drop by too much you know it's
it's important but Dan still holds the
franchise close to his heart you'll want
to be involved with everything
well producer writer right producer
right not so much the acting anymore I'm
kind of I've done it well I guess we're
all getting up there which brings me to
chatting with you with your sunglasses
on I was gonna say this well I knew
there but the doctors have told me
because of a spot on my cornea that the
flashbulbs from my long years of walking
red carpet are not affecting my sight
and I need my two eyes because I ride a
harley-davidson motorcycle dance also
been forced to take good care of his
overall health after being rushed to a
Santa Monica Hospital last month eat a
bad clam sometimes it can it can land it
hurts it hurts you know once they put me
on the dilaudid though I was fine and
then I and I walked out the next morning
and I don't eat clams and why I had that
one I'll try this try this I don't eat
try this try doesn't sit right so he
doesn't eat clams but Dan does love a
good drink especially his own brand
crystal head Aurora vodka we just
thought we wanted to do something a
little fun a little different something
would make maybe a better Bloody Mary
this is spicier